Florence Widdecombe says she felt a bit
shocked she was at home writing
Christmas cards when she found a message
inside one of them day that we got them
we opened them about a week ago and we
were like to get them and about on my
sixth or eighth card
there was somebody all do write it what
in it it had already written in it the
message was written in English it reads
we are foreign prisoners in Shanghai
Ching poo prison China forced to work
against our will please help us and
notify human rights organization the
message also asked that the note be
passed on to British journalist Peter
Humphrey Humphrey and his wife were
formally jailed in China and spent time
in the same prison where the note claims
to be from when I was there
manufacturing labor work was voluntary
you know prisoners could could do that
as a way to earn the pennies that they
need to buy daily necessities like soap
and toothpaste and biscuits that is what
has happened in the last year or so as
that work has become compulsory Tesco
says it has a system in place to check
from manufacturing irregularities and
that it bans the use of prison labor for
now the cards are no longer on sale if
the Chinese company that supplied them
is found to have breached the ban Tesco
says it will permanently remove its
products from its shelves